why are we step through them and see how
we go so number one I just gave you a
plane over cable but this is what one
little tiny curveball thrown in there is
ok if you want by various spheres to be
bold we need to set up this and this and
this in a right angle triangle that's
useful because the air rectangle is
length or five times with right and that
25 got there what it's done it's the
hypotenuse it's a hole into the running
triangle it's the diagonal of the
rectangle we can use diagonal sometimes
for calculating area but not with
rectangle you don't need to those are
far more easy to care for so this is a
724 45 triangle so readers correctly
worked out what we did and then you just
multiply through the good work number
two there was another extra step here
I've given any dimension dimitra's which
means you can go from one to three to a
free additional measure which is told
you so you can see that here in line
running get back up so what do you know
I'm in smoke like what is he actually
calculating someone this is a narrow
area of the group's page yes it has it
his face on the front we're also call it
but like when it dispenser
knowledge-based why is the triangle
where was it it's the cross-sectional
area right now he's on the cross
sectional area what's the second line
doing he's multiplied by lightning okay
so I you could describe this is like at
that's fine I think I'm better way to
describe it is as the perpendicular
height I know that weird because you
aren't even want to happen if you want I
want well no sir I didn't it's political
to the base for us prisoner what we're
interested in is tough is perpendicular
to the cross section which is right
there on the front you agree with that
yeah so I actually think it will help
recall that the person
I from Beauty deal what's he done this
is the conversion and you may remember
we did this exact conversion yesterday
and we say one meter by one meter by one
meter that's a really big Q right so
every one of their attention how do we
need it I just want to show you bring a
problem this are this Q here is exactly
ten centimeters by 10 7 x I don't have
enough hands 10 centimeters okay so 10 x
10 x 10 gives you one needle so just how
dramatically with it ten by ten i can
give you a thousand cubic centimeters
which in turn give cheerleader so I know
if you look at that and think Oh leo I
always picture a milk bottle when I
think of a later I miss Dalton crime
national because it's sort of a stick-up
that's why it works this is exactly
later this is all over all right lots on
the telly business solutions okay there
any employee who agreed to this solution
plan okay so few hands up but also what
hang down so we need to sort out it is
correct or not I could get you every
line of working but there's a quicker
way I want direct way I can check you
know like this just for me lately I feel
some shoes back in right so let's just
test it out they wrote a left hand side
i'm going to try out maybe 17 maybe 17
take away 3 1 full negative 7 plus sorry
Mary some team plus 1 on 2 okay can you
help me on a little bit what's going to
happen with this guy's what's it's going
to be on the top come on the top is this
is negative 2320 you / for that gives
you 5 negative 5 negative 5 right yeah i
was at this one be careful we'll worry
about this heart first that's negative
16 you divide that by 2 you get negative
8 but I'm subtract
midnight so that means this yes do you
agree yeah so that is free is that a lot
of what yeah the right side started in a
freaking looks fine to me now a lot of
people didn't have the info i just want
to point out because i'm interested when
I was watching this working go up
there's a couple things point out maybe
I know some people in order to in
particular I'm among other thing I'm
looking at this line here now
increasingly there is actually an area
miss Lyman we'll talk about in a second
but others are measured us in writing
the error actually gets picked up in the
next life just why the answer is correct
can I oh and tell me what's the issue
with deployment your tell me okay what
do you think oh my oh my ok so to
understand why I want to figure what are
those what is the solution God what's
it's doing from first time the second
one what's actually happening to change
this into the Stars very helpfully
actually written what's she doing she is
multiplying every single object by by
the same number which in this case is
eight she's x truth then she's x 4 do
you agree do you see what she's done up
I've industry on the right hand side
right three until then did we for you x
8 which was great but I mean k identify
Bora this should be in my default one
why is that
okay okay okay I want you to repeat that
again except what everyone can see that
exactly right and they were like five
hands up so people who agree with solid
solution even though it's perfect ok so
we detention for sure to repeat that
again adopted minor fun create online is
like click the license pattern and is
fussing okay so this is a bit tricky
right this minus sign it applies to the
entire fraction you agree so even though
I haven't written it they're kind of
racket here to notice that is what it
implies but it has to write them cuz
it's one fashion right therefore on this
next slide this motor size applies to
everything inside the brackets that
floor are there so minus 4x but there's
also a minus for now do you notice I
didn't account in sugar slowly but now
actually fix it up here because do that
money 10 gigi does actually correct
because minus 6 might fall easy in fact
minus 10 do you notice that and that's
why the answer is true it okay let me
point out one more thing could I agree
with the solution sergeant at this point
CR 2 x 8 and it works out you can
actually x 20 likes too much 100 or 50
billion you'll feel everything we still
staying fine x 80 actually make things a
little bit harder than they should be
because i can multiply by a smaller
number that still fixes everything up
lata rhetorical questions why is she x 8
18 and not say nine or 11 yeah because
she was looking at the season
four times today and abilities now you
can see the lowest common multiple will
get rid of these fractions that's what
she's trying to do that's why the second
line is much better than the first their
mere fraction there okay however the
lowest common multiple of 2 and four is
not actually eight is for like four is a
bottle itself and for the muscles too so
i can multiply your future by ford's
better eight and it will come out
quicker the numbers will be easier okay
but this is not wrong like this is still
become dull there's a lot of fun working
there the good jobs you got that
minister team to their policy period yes
lovely easy question okay